at four they TR to throw for it worthy
stopped short four place from the one
they can't get
in an Oklahoma goal line stand that just
became part of the lore of this rivalry
Billy Bowman got there stand
[Music]
believable U protecting a seven-point
lead back to work from the
one we was at a big afternoon made the
pick early now Brooks makes the cut his
Bas Brooks accelerates Texas
[Applause]
touchdown
Gabriel P just touchdown Nick
[Applause]
Anderson standing on the goal line
waiting for the throw ERS hoping for
time to launch they come after him does
step forward hit as he throws a high
ball near the goal line broke it up batt
it down Oklahoma wins
it